Well go south with me today.
We're going to take up this question initially of
it's an old,
old,
old American question.
How peculiar or distinctive or different is the American south?
That used to be a question you could ask in quite some comfort.
The Dixie difference as a recent book title called it or Dixie rising is another
recent book title called it.
Um,
the south of course as many,
many,
many things,
many peoples.
There are so many south today that has rendered this question
in some ways almost irrelevant,
but in other ways,
of course not.
We still keep finding our presidential elections won or lost in the south
named me and modern American president who won the presidency without at least
some success in the states of the old confederacy.
Look at the great re alignments in American political history.
They've had a great deal to do with the way the south would go or parts of the
south would go.
We're on the verge now,
the first southern primary in this year's election in South Carolina and
everybody is wondering,
is there a new modern South Carolina or not?
Now
this question is fun to have fun with in some ways because it's fraught with
stereotypes,
isn't it?
The south
hot,
slow,
long vowels,
great storytellers and so on.
Oh,
and they love violence and football and stock,
car racing and et Cetera,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I grew up in Michigan and not going to assure you that Michigan,
there's level,
all those things too and probably even more,
but the idea of southern stereotypes is very,
very old.
It isn't a product of the civil war by any means.
The South as an idea,
the south and its distinctiveness was very much there.
Even in the colonial period.
Travelers from England and elsewhere,
France,
who would come to the American colonies would travel throughout the colonies,
would often comment on this that somehow southerners were different culturally,
attitudinally,
behaviorally,
and none other than Thomas Jefferson himself left this famous
description of characterizations of southerners and northerners.
He wrote this in the mid seventies and eighties he was writing to a foreign,
a French correspondent
and Thomas Jefferson describe the people of the north is in the 1780s now than
before the cotton boom and all that.
He described the people of the north this way.
Jefferson northerners are cool,
sober,
laborious,
persevering,
independent,
jealous of their own liberties,
chick canning,
superstitious and hypocritical in their religion.
Take that Yankees,
but southern or is he said they are fiery,
voluptuous,
indolent,
unsteady,
independent,
zealous of their own liberties.
He Changed Jealous,
does zealous there.
If we're doing close readings,
we might,
you know,
go into that for 20 minutes,
but we're not,
he's not over Gel.
The zealous of it own liberties,
but trampling on those of others.
Generous,
candid,
and without attachment or pretensions to any religion,
but that have their own heart.
Yeah,
we can debate what Jefferson got right or wrong there or what's held up,
but do know how he said both sides or either jealous or zealous of their own
liberties.
That could be an upper graph on this course if you like,
because in the end when this civil war will finally come,
both sides will say over and over and over again that they are only fighting for
liberty.
Everybody in the civil war will say they're fighting for liberty.
Um,
and one of the greatest books ever written on the south by a southerner in
particular,
Wilbur caches.
Great classic in 1940
called the mind of the south.
He,
uh,
did something similar at Jefferson,
although he's focusing only on southerners here.
Cash was a great journalist,
intellectual historian in his own right,
deeply critical of his beloved south.
In fact,
it was cash.
He wrote a book called the mind of the south in which he argued in part the
south had no mind,
okay?
He didn't really mean it.
He said,
southerners are proud,
brave,
honorable by.
It's like the south is proud,
brave,
honorable by its lights,
courteous,
personally,
generous,
loyal.
Swift do act often to swift,
but signally effective,
sometimes terrible in its actions.
Such was the south at its best,
said cash and such at its best.
It remains today.
Then comes up,
but at the southeast says is also characterized by violence,
intolerance of versions,
suspicion toward new ideas and in capability for analysis and inclination to act
from feeling rather than from thought attachment to fictions and faults.
Values above all to great attachment to racial values and a tendency to justify
cruelty and injustice.
Some of the south greatest critics of course
have been southern.
What's distinctive about the south?
Just specialty.
There's old,
so
there's Shelby Foote to comment on this.
None other than shall be the star of Ken Burns film series on the civil war.
That lovely,
lovely,
lovely geriatric and a blue shirt that American women's fell in love with and a
documentary film.
It's the only time in recorded history that anyone fell in love with anybody in
a documentary.
Shelby Foote said this,
and who is he speaking for?
I'm not aware that there is such a thing as southern art said,
Shelby,
at least not if you're defining it by technique.
If there's something distinct about it.
Southern Art,
it's subject matter and also inner heritage.
Awesome.
Southerners who tried to express themselves in art are very much aware that they
are a party to a defeat.
No,
that's Shelby Foote speaking for white southerners.
And when Shelby Foote uses the term southerner,
he means white southerners,
but party to a defeat or as Walker Percy,
the great southern writer was once asked,
he was asked in effect,
why does southerners has such long memories?
They don't seem to forget anything.
And he gave us simple straight declarative answer.
He said,
because we lost the war.
We lost loss always.
Yeah.
I think almost always,
especially in modern history,
has led the longer,
deeper troubled memories.
But Shelby wasn't speaking for all southerners.
They're Toni Morrison was speaking for Black Southerners.
And that I think fantastic line in her novel,
Beloved,
which I know many of you have read because it's taught all the time,
but there's a marvelous little exchange at one point between Paul d and Saffie,
Paul d and Seth,
you're trying to imagine a new life out of the horror of their past.
And at one point Paul de simply says the Sethy Sethy of course,
as a former slave woman who was birth of this child,
which becomes this extraordinary ghost called beloved.
And Paul d was former slave who survived the worst brutalities of slavery and
worse than chain gangs and and so on and so forth.
But at one point he just says to her,
me and you Sethi,
we got too much yesterday.
We need more tomorrow.
Too much yesterday.
Why does the south half such a long memory,
why is history and memory sometimes a deep family matter to southerners or as it
isn't necessarily to northerners or so it seemed
okay,
Faulkner captured this.
Faulkner capture does all over the place with the,
I have a favorite line in his novel called the hamlet where Faulkner has one of
his characters say,
and I quote,
only thank God men have done learn how to forget quick what they ain't brave
enough to cure,
can't curate,
can't solve it.
Can you get rid of it?
Forget it or try to forget it or work on forgetting it or create a structure of
forgetting,
which is of course always a structure of remembering at the same time.
And then lastly,
there's Alan Greer,
gayness,
wonderful modern southern writer who wrote that book called the oldest
confederate widow tells all,
you know,
that bizarre.
It's a wonderful read.
We've always been looking for the oldest confederate widow in case you haven't
noticed.
They keep finding one.
The latest was just found another five years ago or so.
She was,
I don't know,
90 and she married some 60 year old confederate veteran.
At some point in time.
We're always finding some woman alive with claim.
She was married to a confederate soldier.
I don't know precisely why that's one for an anthropologist to to figure out,
but Alan could gain is,
he actually said this in the New York Times in a commentary he wrote on the
confederate flag.
Whereas a southern writer back during,
oh about five years ago during the worst of the controversies over the
confederate flag flying on South Carolina capital and so on.
Your gayness wrote this wonderfully witty,
wry,
brilliant op ed piece,
long op Ed in the New York Times where he talked about the depth of southern
memory and white southerners have such deep memories.
And then he begged his fellow southerners the fold,
that battle flag and put it in museums.
But the line I wrote down out of that piece was this,
what's distinctive about the south?
The south has a tradition,
said Greg Louganis of attempting the impossible at great cost,
proudly celebrating the failure and then gaining admiration for the performance,
trying something failing gloriously at it,
getting everybody's admiration.
Okay.
If that's not a novelist description of what a loss causes,
I've never read one.
Uh,
one could go on and on here.
I mean,
in some ways the most distinctive literature America has is a kind of southern
literature,
white and black,
every major African American writer of the 20th century,
at least until your lifetime when black writers in this country are now born and
raised in cities in California or Minneapolis or New York or modern Atlanta,
and they come from all,
all the same places other Americans do.
Sometimes they come from the Caribbean and become Americans,
but that's recent.
Every major African American poet and writer and artists from frankly the mid
19th century on has always been reflecting on this nexus of north and south
south to a very old place as an Albert Murray's famous book,
trouble the water novel about growing up in the south by Melvin Dixon and great
novel.
It gets little attention and his life long struggle to understand just how
southern he was in New York,
Ralph Ellison's famous musings being the southern or come to Harlem and on and
on and on.
Okay,
but let's go back to the old south,
this old south that got the United States in so much trouble,
although wasn't all their fault.
First of all,
it's worth remembering.
There are a lot of clear,
undeniable similarities.
I've all kinds things you can,
you know,
you can measure between south and north in the 40 years before the civil war
north and the south had roughly is the northern and southern states.
The free states and slave states had roughly the same geographic size.
Yeah,
it spoke the same language English,
although in very different regional dialects of course.
Okay.
They had common heroes and common customs and a certain common heritage of the
American revolution.
Make no mistake,
John C.
Calhoun,
one of the great intellectual architects of southern distinctiveness or southern
sectionalism and certainly of southern,
um,
states' rights doctrine.
Okay.
Was very much an American nationalist,
at least in the early parts of his career.
Northerners and southerners shared basically the same Protestant Christianity,
although they used it in different ways.
They have very similar political ideologies.
A born of the Republican ism,
they all kind of breathed in that was breathed into them and they inherited from
the age of the American revolution,
a fierce belief in individual liberty.
When you hear a slave holder preach about his individual liberty and his rights,
you sometimes wonder,
come on,
what do you get off?
But as many of you know,
certainly you will find out here
they had pretty clear ideas of who wat to have those individual liberties and
who would not,
who indeed were born equal and who are not.
Okay.
Both share both sides of the leadership of both sides shared a rich kind of
nationalism
about this American experiment.
You can find a hope that you can stop,
find a deep and abiding kind of American nationalism to steel and a lot of
these,
a budding southern patriots,
even by the 1850 especially when they get scared about what's the session might
actually mean.
You could argue that both southerners and northerners shared a certain degree of
old fashioned American localism attachment to place new Englanders know
something about attachment to place.
And so did people from the low country,
South Carolina
states' rights was nothing that the south owned either.
Of course,
some of the most open exercises,
the state's rights of course before the 1850s were were conducted by
northerners.
Like in the Hartford Convention of 1814.
Well,
I can,
personal liberty laws will come to a bit later in resistance to the fugitive
slave act,
the state of Wisconsin and acted a personal liberty law that said they were not
going to enforce the fugitive slave act and turn in future the slaves.
And the justification was it was that it was their state's right to do so.
So it doesn't just states' rights to this southern,
southern or shared with northern as a faith in progress if you breathe in the
air in America and the 1840s and 50s,
uh,
the idea that America stood for some kind of progress,
that it,
that it didn't American meant a prosperous future was just common coin.
And both southerners and northerners shared both the reality and the spirit of
that westward movement.
Yeah.
Both of them participated in the,
what David Donald used to call the great American,
uh,
practice or custom tradition actually,
he called it,
of compromise
and both sides,
both north and south in their political leadership and their economic
leadership.
We're led by a hard boiled believing,
practicing capitalist southern slave holders.
We're not pre capitalists.
There's historical scholarship that used to argue that a couple of generations
ago,
but not anymore.
And throw this statistic up.
You could argue that both sides had essentially the same kind of oligarchies,
less than 1% less than 1% of the real and personal property in both south and
north by the 1850s was held by approximately 50% of free adult males.
Okay.
The richest 1% in both sections put another way,
held 27% of all the wealth the north had.
I'll budding oligarchies just like the south did.
Oh,
it was Al [inaudible] were based on different things
and that's where the rub came
a little more on this distinct south.
Um,
I said earlier that this is an old idea.
I mean it goes back into the 18th.
You can find all kinds of examples of these stereotypical conceptions of the
south and French British visitors.
I,
one of the most famous Hector Saint John Decrepit core,
who in his famous fictional letters,
letters from an American farmer,
um,
he invented a character.
If you've ever read that great text called farmer James is typical American
farmer.
Farmer James was of course a Pennsylvania Sturdy,
probably had some German blood in him.
[inaudible] made the north the sight of the true essence of what he saw as this
new American man being born in America,
not in the south.
He traveled in the south,
he liked in Charleston,
South Carolina.
Though this isn't the seventies and eighties,
he liked in Charles Sarc,
Charleston,
South Carolina,
to what he called the barbarous institutions and traits,
especially slavery,
the Self Indulgence of the planters.
Um,
and then he concludes just like Lima,
Peru,
that's the only known comparison of Charleston to Lima,
Peru than I'm aware of.
Oh,
and on and on and on,
there were travelers from Europe who came and would write these stereotypic
stories.
There's one by a,
an English traveler.
He entitled it a Georgia planters method of spending time.
And it's this litany of how Georgia planner gets up early,
has this first draft of whiskey,
talks to his overseer as another draft.
The whiskey.
Eight o'clock has breakfast now,
the draft,
the whisky and the day goes and talks to his overseer.
Again,
gets things started on the plantation that day and then he goes into the village
to the tavern,
just start drinking
lots of these most importantly,
seriously.
The idea of the south as exotic,
different and dangerous is an old idea.
A new layer of danger sort of was put on top of images of the south,
uh,
not just to northerners minds for that matter.
After the Great Haitian revolution,
after the slave rebels of sand domain made Haiti the first black republican
modern history and someones Haitian rebels ended up in the American south.
And the imagination of southern white southerners are a lot more Haitian rebels
coming into the south and actually ever,
ever got here.
But then if you look at the writings of new Englanders by the early 19th
century,
take Jedediah Morris for example,
the great geographer he called the north.
Hey quote,
happy state of mediocrity are hardy race of free independent Republicans.
And isn't that the Hamilton that New England has always one of them.
So they don't share anything with a free and independent.
Well,
my wife and I first moved to Amherst,
Massachusetts.
I took a job there at once.
We took,
uh,
some baked goods over to our neighbors and we'd been warned about new Englanders
and all that and delivered baked goods.
Does that high.
All right,
we're here now.
And a woman sat in effect.
Why have you brought this
anyway,
sorry.
Jedediah Morris described southerners,
however,
as quote,
just constant lint and that represented,
he said by quote,
disconsolate wildness and popular ignorance.
Noah Webster of the great dictionary of fame said famously,
Oh,
New England,
how superior are thy habits in morals,
literature,
civility and industry.
So
pairing the north and the south,
trying to understand how difference eventually does bullying into political
crisis,
which eventually boils into conflict,
which eventually boils into disunion,
which eventually boils into war,
does have some root back in these kinds of perceived differences.
There's one of my favorite historians warned me once,
don't leave out the politics.
Don't leave out politics now.
Um,
if I could
hang your hat on one kind of southern distinctiveness,
perhaps above or it's fun to play with all these stereotypes and realize that if
so many people were writing this way from personal observation,
yeah,
there must be something to all these differences,
but what eventually evolved in the south,
and we will return to this a good deal next Tuesday when I'll devote an entire
lecture to this kind of slave holder worldview and the pro slavery argument,
the pro slavery defense and how that evolved into a political culture.
But if there's one thing,
and this is a little risky because they're always holds in any claim like this,
but it is one distinct feature of old,
the old south society and indeed its leadership and most of its people,
it would be what we might label anti modernism.
It was a society
that eventually developed a disdain for what they perceived as the corruptions
of modern commercialism.
Southern slave holding leadership in particular were very suspicious of the
spread of literacy.
Yeah.
They were very suspicious of the democratic tendencies or so it seemed the
democratic tendencies of that northern society,
which was spreading literacy more widely and eventually the right to vote more
widely,
at least among white people.
It is a society where the leadership for sure and much of the non-leadership
we're suspicious of reform,
suspicious of change,
suspicious of democracy itself,
democracy,
the slave holding class of the south came to seed,
small d as a dangerous thing.
It was a threat to hierarchy and the south became quite distinctively a very
hierarchical society.
More on that in just a second.
It became a hierarchical society rooted very deeply and an open conceptions of
class and obviously open conceptions of race.
Some were born to rule
in the overall attitude of the,
of the planter class in the leadership class of the American south by the 1840
[inaudible] and 1850s some were born to rule and some born to be ruled
deal with.
It was their attitude.
They became deeply protective and insistent upon their own peculiar sense.
And it was a great scholarship on this.
Their own peculiar sense
of honor,
honor,
uh,
old fashioned concept.
It's an old fashioned word.
How many of you even use that word anymore?
Do the honorable thing.
Uh,
Oh,
I didn't act today with much honor did I?
We're more likely to,
we have other words for it now.
What would,
what would the,
we might say class,
we did that with class or uh,
or being effective.
Um,
I dunno.
What would a synonym date today
for honor
anyone
a good synonym for honor.
A person of character.
Okay.
Oh,
I dunno.
You,
you keep working on that.
Where are you sending them for honor?
Well,
honor in the old,
so there's a whole vast scholarship on this and uh,
two or three of the teachings citizens in this class are real experts on it.
So take it up with Steve and Sam and others.
But it was essentially a set of values and it's deep and it was a deeply rooted,
a set of values in the planters worldview.
Okay.
It was a form of behavior.
Demeanor.
Yes.
It meant a certain kind of gentleman's understanding of behavior.
Okay.
It was the idea that a gentleman must be honest,
a gentleman must be trustworthy.
A gentleman was a man of entitlement.
A gentleman was a man of property,
a gentleman had class rank and status and you better recognize it.
And the most important thing and the southern code of honor,
I think safe to say was reputation.
A man of honor must be recognized.
It must be acknowledged.
And indeed there must be virtually a ritual of that recognition.
The honor is alive and well around the world today.
And make no mistake,
I mean it's alive and well in diplomacy.
It's alive and well in many,
many cultures.
Uh,
I was part of a huge conference last summer and in West Africa on the end of the
slave trade in Ghana.
And we had representative,
we have people participating in that conference from 15 or 16 different African
countries.
We had African chieftains involved.
We are the vice president of Ghana and the president of Togo and on and on and
on.
We spend an entire day doing nothing but borrowing and doing honor.
And for Americans,
all our democratic experience.
And do I have to put a tie on for this event or not?
Uh,
you know,
this,
this kind of ritual on her all the time.
I mean,
after all,
we have a president who just likes to speak like a Texan,
you know,
and do all that honors stuff.
I'm sorry if I'm going to do Bush,
I got to work on that.
Don't,
and that's terrible.
What's that guy that does those commercials?
He's brilliant at Bush.
Um,
um,
I forget.
Anyway,
James Henry Hammond of South Carolina once said,
I quote,
reputation is everything.
Everything with me depends upon the estimation in which I am held.
That's honor.
Personal honor.
For many southerners,
it was more important than law,
more important than conscience.
And when they started encountering these northerners,
okay,
whether they're from Massachusetts or Ohio,
yeah,
we started talking about a politics of conscience
or a politics of law.
Okay.
They're not always talking
on the same page.
So anti modernism and honor our two hooks,
you can hang your hats on.
They're all those other claims.
You know,
the south is distinctive because of its climate,
hot weather,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
This book after book after book on this like Clarence case in his famous book,
90 degrees in the shade,
which is supposed to explain all of southern behavior and ideas.
Ruralness is often used to explain the distinctiveness of southern,
uh,
writing and art and so on.
I do love Eudora Welty.
His description of this,
she didn't just say it's all because the south is rural,
but Eudora Welty was once asked why southerners can be such great writers
are such good story tellers and she was a wonderful storyteller.
Her answer was this,
and it's got something to do with how the last cars took hold to,
but she said southerners love a good tale.
Okay.
There are born reciters great memory retainers,
diary keepers,
letter exchangers and letters,
savers,
history,
tracers and debaters and out staying all the rest.
They are just great talkers.
No,
I met a few New England.
Is there a good talkers too?
Then there's this issue of conservatism.
Why is the south the seat of American conservatism?
Why did a southern strategy in modern American political history reinvent the
Republican Party?
Uh,
even though some defenders of that particular movement claim it didn't happen.
Like David Brooks tried to claim in the New York Times.
David Brooks is a revisionist.
Well,
the tap root of conservatism you could say is right there in the old south.
It's exactly what,
uh,
Wilbur cash once said,
he said,
if you want understand the south,
he said it's taproot is back there in the old south.
We so long had this,
a game of sort of always looking for the central theme of southern history.
Now the central theme of the south.
And so often it does come back to this overall claim of a kind of anti reform,
sometimes even anti intellectual conservative defense of a hierarchical
civilization rooted in white supremacy and originally deed and one of the
biggest slave systems the world had ever created.
And there was the old business about violence.
Uh,
you can go away to the lots of books on this and articles on this.
Why cockfighting was more popular in the south.
Why white country fighting an eye gouging was Elliot Garner.
A wonderful historian up at Brown wrote a brilliant,
fascinating half crazy essay once about eye gouging in southern fighting.
And
I dunno,
I used to love to quote from it,
but then I began to realize I'm only quoting that because it's about a guy's eye
being gouged out.
So that's not going to do that anymore.
Okay,
now see,
van Woodward weighed in on this great historian,
worked here much of his life,
but he said,
you know,
finally the south,
he said,
finally the South got liberated from being the place that America always dumped
its sins
and his famous book of essays,
the burden of southern history among many other things.
He argued that the south actually had the chance to finally be liberated from
being deceit of all of America's sins
by three things.
He didn't live long enough quite too well.
He actually lived long enough,
but he didn't really write about what I would add as a fourth one.
But he said,
the civil rights revolution finally begin to liberate this out.
And concomitantly.
A second reason is that that civil rights revolution also brought through it's
process,
a huge discovery.
At the same time off northern racism when Martin Luther King brought the
movement to Chicago and nearly got killed doing it.
Okay.
And in a thousand other ways,
Americans realize,
you know,
racism isn't a southern thing.
It's everywhere,
belongs to everyone.
And then Woodward argued quite directly that the loss of the Vietnam war began
to liberate the south in a sense that the south southerners,
White southerners,
were the only Americans other than we always forget,
native Americans who had ever lost a war.
And then a burden was taken off the south by the loss of that Vietnam War.
Now that's a debatable subject,
isn't it?
Because there's a broad revisionism about Vietnam.
Ronald Reagan argued it was our,
our noble cause in Vietnam we could won,
should have won,
we're winning
and so on and so forth.
There's even a fourth idea you might add to how the south may have been a little
bit liberated from this past by what has happened in just the last 20 to 25
years of American political history
and economic history with sunbelt migration,
with southern industrialization and post industrialization with massive
immigration now from around the world,
large Vietnamese populations in Louisiana,
large Hispanic populations in North Carolina,
uh,
huge Cuban and other Hispanic populations in Florida.
You have a very,
very changing demographic situation in the American south and its political
culture has to respond to that.
So we may live in your lifetime to a time when this burden of southern history
may get all but lifted all together from southerners.
Unless,
yeah,
we don't forget the civil war and we don't seem to forget it.
As I said the other day,
if that confederate flag would just go away,
just just vanish,
just stick it in the basement of museums and no one would ever care about it
anymore.
Maybe,
maybe
sounds burden would go away.
But there's another kind of burden,
and again,
Woodward and many others have written about this.
One of the most distinctive things about southern the south is of course it's
history.
Not just it's cultural,
not just its attitudes,
not just its behavior,
not the kind of stuff that's,
uh,
what's his name?
Um,
um,
John Shelton read the great sociologist has always doing these surveys of
attitudes about southerners of Southerners by Southerners.
But let's remember the south had a distinctive history.
Yeah.
The antebellum southern economy became by the 1820s without any question,
a slave economy.
And by the 1820 [inaudible] and 1830s,
the American south became,
what I think you could safely say was the fifth slave society in human history,
maybe the sixth.
This is a debatable
now for a long time in American scholarship and an American classrooms.
One of the deep mythologies about this whole story of the year of the American
civil war and the old south is that the old south plantation economy was dying
out.
Soil was being eroded and wasted along the eastern seaboard.
And they were using up the great soils of the Mississippi Valley.
And over time,
that slave system just somehow wasn't gonna.
I wasn't gonna work out
now.
Oh,
Rick Phillips argued this years and years and years ago.
Others argued from real research.
But along came Robert Fogel and Stanley Angerman and a generation of other
scholars from the 1960s on.
And there were people in before them who looked at the southern economy through
clear metrics and statistics and a broad swath of new economic historical
methods and analyses.
And they discovered that,
sorry folks,
slavery was extremely profitable.
The southern economy.
Thank you very much.
Was booming south had its greatest cotton crop ever in 1860.
It was affected by the major American depressions of 80 and 37,
857 but not as much as the north.
Okay.
And Lo and behold,
that idea we had of the southern planter as this,
oh,
you know,
kind of anti modern,
don't give up entirely on the anti modern label.
I think there's still something to that.
But that anti modern kind of backward looking,
um,
planter who,
uh,
you know,
he didn't really like world markets.
He didn't like railroads and trains and all that stuff.
He just wanted to make a decent little living.
If he could off growing some Hamptons and tobacco and indigo and some rice and
some cotton,
and he was good to as slaves.
They had a bad break coming from Africa.
But you know,
it's the way it goes.
[inaudible]
we know.
We now know if we know anything about the old south,
the average American plants are they average American slave holders,
small and big ones were raging capitalists.
They understood markets,
they understood profits.
They were men of rational choice and the way to wealth in the American south,
the way to wealth,
even before the cartons yen,
but especially after Eli Whitney's cotton gin.
And by the way,
folks,
everybody knows Eli Whitney invented the cotton gin and was this originally,
there's a little box smaller than this lectern.
If you don't know that somebody should have taught you that in the sixth grade
or fourth grade or first grade or somewhere good old Eli Whitney and all,
it's his fault.
We had the cotton boom and slavery grew and you got to turn Eli Whitney to the
civil war
and then we have a great war for weeks,
you know,
and it's all Eli Whitney.
He's buried right across the street.
Go into Grove Street cemetery.
So to go visit his grave and say,
it's not your fault,
Eli,
it's okay.
Cause then planners there were raging capital's just waiting for you.
All you did is give them a machine.
Yeah.
The way to wealth.
Faulkner wrote about this too,
in that immortal character he created and Thomas Sutton and Absalom,
Absalom,
who is Thomas Sutton,
Thomas Sutton is that guy who arrives out in Alabama with a group of Haitian
slaves with them.
He treats him like a absolute tyrant.
He carves down the forest,
he begins to cultivate the land and he declares what your God I have for success
in the south is a house,
some land and some niggers.
That's another one of those sentences by Faulkner that sort of captured this
spirit of Alabama fever as it was called the 1820s and thirties and Mississippi
fever in the 1830 [inaudible] wheezy Deanna,
Texas fever by the 18 why Louisiana fevers or been earlier,
but Texas fever by the 1840 land was so rich and it was really cheap at first.
Now how powerful
was the cotton boom once it took hold?
MMM,
this powerful sea island cotton,
the kind of cotton grown down there and the Georgia where it was first grown in
North America and the Georgia South Carolina islands was it kind of long and
silky kind of cotton and they weren't very successful in growing it in huge
amounts,
but that's short staple car that eventually was the form of cotton that the
cotton gin made into such a massive marketable world product is what made the
cotton boom boom by the 1820s already within a decade of the war of 1812 and the
opening of the frontier cottons future seems limitless.
And one of the best analogies you can think of is the oil rich nations of the
world in post World War II and the post World War Two era,
whether it's Saudi Arabia,
Iraq and Iran,
the Emirates or Venezuela name today,
Russia,
if you're an oil rich country today,
as long as that oil last you got the,
you got the world kind of,
it's your knees,
you're an OPEC,
and that is exactly what the south began to see itself as.
At least southern leadership began to see itself as as early as the 1820s and
1830s
the cotton crop nearly doubled every decade from 1820 to 1864 decades in a row,
the production of American cotton nearly doubled.
Now,
think of another product in American history that doubled every decade for four
decades,
and then imagine that that product became the countries without question.
Absolute largest export
general motors at its height.
When I was growing up in Flint,
Michigan in boom times would have wished it could have said that
already by 1825 that early the south was the world's largest supplier of cotton
and fueling.
Now this dust,
real revolution in textile production and Great Britain and other places,
and think of it this way.
Um,
I need a map for this.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
Oh right.
I pushed the right button.
I know you can't see that very well.
Okay.
I think I can zoom though.
Hey,
cool.
Well,
I don't know if you can see those colors much at all.
Sorry about that.
Um,
but what you've got at the top or the early 17 nine and in the 1820 in terms of
of slave population in the American south.
But if you look at 1860 the bottom map,
if you can vaguely see those deep dark red areas,
you can see where cotton moved,
where slavery moved in the domestic slave trade,
and then where southern political power move.
And you will find as we will in the next few weeks,
the southern political power by the 1850 [inaudible] and 1860s is really no
longer in Virginia or even South Carolina.
It's out in the Mississippi Valley.
There's a very good reason.
Jefferson Davis becomes president of the confederacy in 1860 is because he's
from Mississippi
now.
Um,
fortunes were made overnight.
New Wealth overnight.
A number of men is one historian has written and I think quite effectively
mounted from log cabin to mansion.
I quote on a stairway of cotton bales accumulating slaves as they went.
If you had five slaves and a good piece of land in Alabama in 1820 you might
very likely have 50 slaves and a hell of a lot more than a decade later,
but it's also worth knowing that that slave holding population was also fluid.
People moved in and out of it.
There were approximately 400,000 slaveholders white slave holders in the
American south by 1860 about one third of southern white families at one time or
another had at least a toe hold in slave ownership.
That means two thirds did not.
Of course,
two thirds of the white south remained in those classes.
We've come to call the yeoman farmers.
The poor whites or the sand hill farmers is,
they were sometimes call in certain regions of the south.
The yeoman farmer,
non slave holding,
but landowning usually and in the poor white farmer,
non slave holding me,
usually not even land owning,
usually renting or working for wage labor.
We're 40 50 and even 60% of the white population in a given region.
Jefferson Davis is in fact a classic example of the cotton boom planter.
He was born in relatively meager and humble circumstances in Kentucky.
Not what about 80 miles from where Abraham Lincoln was born and even meager
circumstances,
but his older brother Joseph went out to Mississippi and struck it rich and
cotton and Jefferson Davis went out to join him and Jefferson Davis became a
millionaire
on cotton.
Chris Jefferson Davis really preferred to be a military officer and went to West
Point on and on and on and the rest is history.
My Watch says I've run out of time now let me leave you with this.
How successful was the cotton boom?
How important was the cotton boom?
What is the relationship between the spread of slavery,
the spread of cotton and power?
By 1860
there were approximately 4 million slaves in the United States.
The third,
the second largest slave societies,
slave population in the world,
the only one larger Russian serfdom,
Brazil was close,
but in 1860 American slaves as a financial asset,
we're worth approximately three and a half billion dollars.
That's just as property.
Okay.
Three and a half billion dollars was the net worth roughly of slaves in 1860 in
today's dollars,
that would be approximately $75 billion in 1860 slaves.
As an asset,
we're worth more than all of America's manufacturing,
all of the railroads,
all of the productive capacity of the United States put together.
Slaves were the single largest by far financial asset of property and the entire
American economy.
The only thing worth more than the slaves in the American economy of the 1850s
was the land itself and no one can really put a dollar value on all of the land
of North America.
If you're looking to begin to understand
why the south will begin to defend this system,
defend the society and worry about it's shrinking and worry about a political
culture from the north that is really beginning to criticize them.
Thank three and a half billion dollars and the largest financial asset in
American society and what you might even try to compare that to today.
I'll pick up with this next Tuesday.
It's a perfect transition into the pro slavery argument
and the southern World View.
Thank you.